we're told that ben's home is x
kilometers from an ice cream shop
jerry's home is y kilometers from the
same shop
then it tells us they each left their
home at the same time and met at the ice
cream shop at the same time
ben
walked an average speed let me just send
a new caller average speed of five
kilometers per hour and jerry
rode his bicycle at an average speed of
v kilometers per hour
write an equation that relates x y and v
pause this video and see if you can do
that
all right so let's just remind ourselves
how distance speed and time are related
you might be familiar with things like
distance is equal to rate times time or
another way you could think about it is
you could write the distance
is equal to speed
times
time
or if you want to solve for time you can
divide both sides by speed so you could
get distance
over speed
over speed
is equal to time
now the reason why i set it up this way
is that we know that ben's time and
jerry's time is the same they covered
maybe different distances at maybe
different speeds but it took them the
exact same amount of time so band's
distance divided by bend speed should be
the same as jerry's distance divided by
jerry speed so let me write that down
so
ben's distance
bends
distance
divided by ben's speed
and let me write it in this color
ben's
ben's speed
should be equal to
jerry's distance
jerry's
distance
divided by
jerry's speed
jerry's
speed
now which of these do we know or do we
already have variables defined well we
know that ben's distance from the ice
cream shop is x so this is represented
by x we know that jerry's distance from
the ice cream shop is represented by y
so this is y
we know that ben's speed is five
kilometers per hour so we're assuming
everything is in kilometers per hour so
this would be five
and then jerry's speed is v kilometers
per hour so this is v
right over there
and so we could rewrite all of this as
x
over 5
is equal to
y
over
v
and once again the way that i set this
up the left side is the amount of time
ben takes to get to the ice cream shop
this is on the right hand side this is
the amount of time jerry takes to get to
the ice cream stop shop and they tell us
it's the same amount of time so there
you have it we have an equation that
relates x y and v and they gave us the
5. now it's completely possible that
instead of the 5 they gave us something
else and bend speed was a variable if
they did that then we would have a
different given and maybe a different
variable but the structure of our
equation would be the same that ben's
distance divided by bend speed
would need to be equal to jerry's
distance divided by jerry's speed